the Joe Rogan experience so we have a
[ __ ] election coming up I'm the heels
of all this [ __ ] and now they're talking
in California about digital elections
and Hillary's behind it so as soon as
Hillary says everyone should be safe to
vote and voting at home oh oh this [ __ ]
is running a game something's going on
everyone's losing a thought everyone's
losing their minds I mean I see all this
stuff to about like foul Chi and the and
gates and the conspiracy theories and
there's it's so hard because so many
conspiracy theories have ended up being
true like pouchy is a virus expert
that's what he's always been right
there's no conspiracy he's a guy no but
that he's in cahoots with Bill Gates and
like they did a whole thing and yeah
he's a guy who's a virus expert virus
expert his whole life if he [ __ ]
waited until he's 70 years old to cash
in his Illuminati chips and this is it
we've been running this scam for years
I've been pretending all these different
diseases in it but they're all horseshit
I'm just evil looking to get paid and
finally it's coming my way no you would
have already cashed in his chips he's
not a bad guy he runs three miles a day
looks like he's healthy he looks vibrant
he's d7 now it's three oh really
yeah cuz II get busy yeah because he's
working on you know the other stuff look
the only conspiracy that gives me pause
is when you see people like Bill Gates
saying we need a we need some sort of a
vaccination we need to vaccinate and
everyone's gonna be vaccinated like okay
but have there ever been a virus that's
ever been there's a real vaccine that
would work for a corona virus I don't
think there has I don't think they've
had I don't think they had a virus they
were working on a vaccine rather they're
working a vaccine for SARS but it never
happened and I don't think they've ever
had any sort of a vaccine for a corona
virus is that way he's saying he's
saying he's saying they need a vaccine
and they're gonna come up with a vaccine
and that's the solution and everybody
has to be vaccinated but I don't know if
that's even will you
the idea is it'll take 18 months for a
vaccine maybe or maybe they won't come
up with one right it's possible that
they won't have a vaccine in 19 months
so what do you want to do bill and if
they do have a vaccine where's the money
go for making the vaccine who's getting
paid how many how many dollars is it
where's that money going like how is it
a business now so if you're having if
you have a vaccine that vaccine turns
out that we had to vaccinate the whole
population okay
so you gonna vaccinate eight billion
people and then where's that money who
gets the money from the manufacture the
vaccine is it you know are you gonna do
it completely egalitarian are you are
you gonna be lying yeah is it free is it
free new coronavirus vaccines are says
finding one by January is a credible
goal okay okay
pharmaceutical executive he sounds like
a character in a movie once
flowey former pharmaceutical executive
at the White House chose to lead a crash
development program acknowledged that
the 12 to 18 month timeline cited by dr.
Anthony foul she was already very
aggressive but a1 by January as possible
a credible goal so maybe it is did you
say here's the thing until they have one
you can't say we got a vaccine to
everybody let's look at all the all the
possibilities did you see that one guy
that was walking around I think Sam
Tripoli had it up on his Instagram page
the guy was walking around at the
protest in Newport it's a pretty new
Porter might have been Huntington Beach
and this guy's walking around with a
megaphone whatever he's saying we open
back up California oh yeah and Bill
Gates is the devil the Bill Gates stuff
is so funny to me it's so weird it
became I know where you either you
either what's how to express that quote
you either you either die a hero you
live long enough to become a villain
he's because he lived long enough to
become a villain right the Gates
Foundation literally gives millions of
dollars away to charity when I was in
Rome and all over the world when you go
to these any of these places you know
what he's done in Africa did you see the
whole documentary like he built freakin
toilets right off of Africa no he's like
making
he literally figures out how to [ __ ]
help them with one of the biggest
problems in Africa and everyone's like
[ __ ] Bill Gates in Rome everything's
crumbling in Greece because they don't
there's they don't have the money to
maintain all their antiquities and so
the Gates Foundation is everywhere
keeping all of the our history basically
from like crumbling but he [ __ ] up
instead of talking about vaccines and
people like you want to get rich off the
backs of all these people you're gonna
inject your microchips into I did I did
a Radiohead and I didn't I know it was a
like a right-wing guy and I didn't
really know much but he he was asking me
out of the blue he's like and then did
you see Melinda Gates there's like our
[ __ ] could you do it when they do these
that's oh my god no I'm like I'm not
gonna get into this whole anti gates
thing but he's done so much good yeah
but to be fair she was out there saying
that there's talking about when we
should open up and vaccines and I'm like
yeah maybe just I keep saying this if I
was rich
you would never [ __ ] hear from me
right now I would be on a beach there's
so much it's a classroom personally it's
a you would still be spouting now stop
your [ __ ] if somebody gave you a
hundred million dollars you would wait
about a month and you'd go right back on
Twitter
[ __ ] yeah you know I'm right you know
I'm right no best tweeters alive no
you're probably right
right about that you're one of the best
tweeters alive this this thing that
they're doing where they're they're
telling people they're gonna have to get
vaccinated this is what there's a part
of the problem because there's a lot of
people that have kicked this disease we
got to figure out why they kicked it
whether it's nutrition whether it's
genetics whether it we've got to figure
that out and this thing that you're
saying we get everybody's got to get
vaccinated
no they don't no they don't it's we
don't even know first of all you don't
even know if they're gonna be able to
nail this vaccine they do I hope they do
yeah that's a we're it's the weird to
see the convergence of the anti-vaxxers
and all of this talk because I wrote a
piece about it was like a satirical
piece I was saying why stop getting
add at anti-vaxxers for bringing disease
into the herd and it was all about it
because it was during like the measles
outbreaks which we've almost eradicated
and now it's making a comeback and
there's so much overlap in those
communities now at this yeah but you
can't really conflate the two because we
know how to get rid of the measles we
know we can get rid of the measles but
we have something that works right but
it's a Liberty thing
yeah problem is whenever you start
telling people what they have to do even
if it's good for them yeah they get mad
[Applause]